on this episode we're going to take a
look at anthony banks of submission for
the logo critique he does something that
i'm a big fan of he did the hand letter
script typeface i'm going to show you
how laying out some guides and
illustrator can really tighten it up and
give it that extra level of polish stick
around having this swoosh or flourish of
the L actually touch here it's making it
hard for me to read this is a little
awkward here - this is a nice flourish
this really completes this thing the
reason why you create the flourishes is
to if there's a lot of white space it
fills it in a little bit so it doesn't
feel so empty that's exactly what it
does so you can see then why he added
this why Anthony out of that because
without it there would be this negative
space in here and he didn't know what to
do with it and I'm also thinking what
the hell I think I've been nice if he
just finished it here that way B doesn't
get confused with this strange ligature
that's been created so now I'm going to
switch over to the pen tool and I'm
going to try to draw the baseline of
this I'm trying to line it up at the
bottom of the Kate you're looking for a
stroke that has flat bottom there we go
we can look at the top of the a that way
that the paint strokes they how it
finishes right there I believe that's
the x-height so now we have some
establishing lines here so I'm noticing
a problem already as I line up the K but
L feels a little short of the K so
there's one thing I'm seeing in Japan
I'm gonna continue to draw some lines
here are some guidelines so I'm gonna
try to match up the stroke wit with
there so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
try to line all these things up because
I want to see what's going on now take
this and I'm gonna hit command v which
will turn it all into a guide let me
point out some things here you do want
the tops of the k2 line up with the top
of L because they're essentially the
shared letter when if you guys took the
topography course and we studied letter
forms there are shared parts between
letters letters that have verticals they
should have shared parts and letters
that are circular in their shape like an
O or the letter C they should have
shared common parts it's not supposed to
look different and that rhythm that
sense that each character is based on
another character
really makes it feel cohesive and that's
some of the principles of lettering here
the see all curved letter forms need to
overshoot it till it feels optically
balanced otherwise it will feel a little
short the bottom of the sea doesn't go
below like that way the a does you see
they over here over shoots a little bit
bottom of a bottom the L little funky
there conversely the top of the sea has
is overshooting the x-height but it's
going a lot higher than that then the a
and there's they should be very similar
if not the same because the lowercase C
and a should be very similar now here's
the good news bad news good news is if
you draw one letter form correctly in
theory you don't have to draw so many
letter forms again and again they're not
meant to be different yes I'm looking at
the way this curves over and the how it
continues through the letter form it
feels like this tapers down if I were to
continue that on an imaginary line it
misses this mark somehow okay okay so I
have a hawk let's try and fix one
problem and see but if by doing that
that solves everything else so I'm gonna
use the cut what it's a scissor tool
which is I think right here and this is
a tools C so I'm gonna select this right
here I'm gonna cut it right there
what kind of right there it's in theory
now I should be able to take these
points and move them away does it read
like black what would they say payable
before yeah payable does it still rely
payable let's see what do you guys think
desert do we improve the legibility we
sought to fix the B for sure maybe if
you use the able down a little bit so
we'll move it down what like that yeah
let's look at more label the Bell
someone says tables not a word we know
that so now we have a new problem though
ladies mm-hmm what's the new problem
that space expand that cover little
space right there yeah we got to go do
something with that make a flourish off
the last L
fill that space that way stuffing into
my brush here she's talking about doing
something like this right yeah something
like that
yeah but we're not gonna solve that
because that takes a like a hundred
sketches for us oh yeah yeah just a
suggestion
but that's what future gotta fill these
things in right okay I don't know how
it's gonna look think of you trace over
100 these kinds of logos it will
eventually come together I want to try
and draw a curve with this few points as
possible so that they're easier to
manipulate so you really didn't need
those points you don't even need this
point you see ya then and then that
ensures that the curve is much nicer and
easier to control you don't have any
weird flat spots and I'm trying to make
the bowl of the bead have a nice smooth
curve and arc to it like the way this
feels this feels really nice to me and
I'm not quite sure what's going on so
this is what we need to work on the
bottom of the bead feels like it's got
some problems too like it's sagging down
the emphasis Taylor watch I'll show you
what I'm talking about if we look at the
thickest point it's right around here so
that if you imagine the pen is being
held at a certain angle and it's being
drawn so these will always be fixed
points so in theory this is the fix
point if I'm being consistent with the
way this is drawn because it's going to
be drawn down it's gonna come back up
and you might turn the pen so here's
where it gets a little funny like
where's the thickest point here it's a
little undecided I think this should
have been the thickest point here to
match these lines so we go thicker here
start to thin out and it'd be thick down
here so if we keep that in mind let's
try to see if we can't adjust this be
here okay I'm not gonna fix it but do
you see how like there's the thickness
here yeah right does it feel a little
bit better yeah what I'm trying to do a
show like this there's a nice thick to
thin transition that I think makes it
look really fun and friendly that's what
we're trying to do I hope you liked this
episode and find it to be informative if
you like it you want to take a deeper
dive be sure to check out our logo
design course and if you want to have
your work critiqued by us by the team
for myself make sure you go on our
Facebook page
look for the call for submissions that's
it for this episode be sure you hit like
comment subscribe and hit that Bell icon
I will see you on the very next episode